[Music]
hello everyone
uh so at the end of uh the previous
recorded video on our discussion of this
jupiter notebook i had mentioned that
it is also possible to do
calculus here using symbolic python so
let's
see a demonstration of that so suppose
we have a function
uh like this let's say x
square the simplest uh one of the
simplest of functions and
suppose we want to differentiate this
with respect to x so all that we have to
do is write
it like sim dot def fm
comma x so that represents that we are
differentiating the function x
function with respect to x and if we do
a shift enter now
we'll get the result as twice x very
easy uh
similarly suppose uh instead of this x
square we had x square times y
uh so or maybe
uh i it will be better if i demonstrate
the
the second derivative uh so
we have this x square suppose i want to
find out the second derivative
i can do that by writing this explicitly
as
x but now with a 2 uh to demonstrate how
to indicate that i need to have the
derivative
done twice and that gives us the correct
result
so next suppose uh we have
another function let's say
x square y and now we want to have
uh a derivative with respect to uh
with respect to x so
just like before we can have g n x
and when you do a shift enter very
correctly we get
twice xy we could also alternatively
uh do a derivative with respect to y
so that gives us x square as you would
expect now
so so this diff operator the same.dif
operator it is
it is like a partial derivative also
okay so we have to understand this
now why are we doing this okay it's good
that it can do calculus
you see in 2d elasticity we have uh we
have been talking about
the edit stress function and the by
harmonic equation so those
do involve partial derivatives okay
similarly if you have the displacement
field
then uh if you need to find out the
the strains using the strain
displacement relations again you will
need to
have derivatives okay so in these sorts
of things
and this the symbolic python will be
very useful
all right so let's see uh uh
let's actually see a demonstration
of uh of this thing in action
okay so now what we'll do is we'll go a
little bit advanced
and uh we'll define a laplacian operator
so what we'll do here is
using this kinds of operations same dot
div
with respect to x and y we will define
uh
a general operator okay
so the way that so when i say define an
operator basically mean that i define a
function
uh so just like let's say
we i mean as a very very simple example
we can define
an add function okay so add
and let's say this add takes in two two
values
uh let's say uh
like a a comma b and then we can just uh
we can can return this as a plus b
okay or i mean any such thing okay
this is the simplest of thing okay so if
we do next a
add uh let's say 4 comma 5
it should give us 9 which it does in a
similar fashion
so this is something this is like a user
defined function
okay so in a similar way we can define a
laplacian
okay now this will operate on a scalar
quantity
so it can also operate on any vector
or any second order tense or anything
but let's just keep
things simple for now okay so this f can
be anything uh but we will demonstrate
using a scalar
uh so what we'll say is i will ask this
function to return
the the laplacian of f now the laplacian
of f is basically within the rectangular
cartesian coordinate system
del square f del x square plus del
square f del y square
okay so we can and do that at one shot
by doing like this
so this is differentiation of f with
respect to x
but done twice plus
differentiation of f with respect to y
but done twice that's it
okay that's the that's the laplacian
operator defined for us
done so now suppose we have
some function okay suppose we have let's
say we we define
a some function h of n uh
and let's say we we define it like
x square plus
y y square
okay so what do you think the laplacian
of this is
so if we differentiate this h of n with
respect to x twice we'll get a two
out of it and if we do uh if we do the
second derivative of h and
or or to the derivative of y
is the derivative of h n with respect to
y twice we'll get a 2
so 2 plus 2 is 4 so that's what we
should get let's see
we can get that so now we're using the
user defined
laplacian operator we input
h into it and let's see if we can so
very correctly it gives us 4. now
suppose
we are interested because we are our
goal ultimately is to go to 2d
elasticity operations
we want to go to the by harmonic
operator okay
now by harmonic again involves the
fourth order derivatives
but remember that by harmonic is
basically laplacian
operated sequentially twice
okay so using that information uh
we can define this by harmonic operator
so
so let me just put a little comment here
using markdown
so i change it to a markdown cell enter
into it
and write it down so next we will define
the by harmonic operator
using the laplacian operator using the
already defined
laplacian operator
okay
maybe i'll just edit a little bit so
next we use
the fact that
that
square of nablus where f
to define the by harmonic operator using
the already defined
already defined
the plus in operator okay so
to see how nicely it has gotten rendered
so next we use the fact that
del 4 phi del 4 f is equal to del square
of del square f
to define the harmonic operator using
the already defined
laplacian operator so f by harmonic
f so now i don't have to write down same
div
f x comma four plus all those other
things
which would be quite lengthy uh instead
i can just write this as
laplacian
uh operating on the laplacian
operating on the laplacian object that's
it
okay so now
let's say we have a little function
uh called agent2
and let's see we have this in the very
simplest of forms as
x4 okay x to the power 4
so what does the bi-harmonic of this
give us
all right that's correct so x to the
power 4
when we uh when you do the derivative of
that with respect to 4 with respect to x
4 times we'll get this thing out all
right
so we can have can also also have other
things
definitely we can have these things and
more other more complicated
expressions now our ultimate aim of
course is to go to
uh edistress functions so
what we'll do is
and please note that it is not only for
specific uh
such specific kind of things that we can
uh we can have these things okay
what i mean to say is that suppose we
have a general function a general
function of
x and y then also we can we can use this
laplacian or the by harmonic operator so
let me demonstrate that actually
uh so suppose we define
a phi okay so very much
an area stress function uh maybe i can
define it like
r5 so same dot
uh so now instead of symbols i will
call this function uh
for five okay so uh
let me just cut it on now
and show you uh maybe
just tell you okay so
what i mean to say is that suppose if i
used phi
okay so this is only for s
one simple thing
okay so i
if this is phi and suppose i had written
it like
bar phi that would be like this
there's a little bit of a difference
between phi and var phi
okay so they look a little bit different
that's what i mean so now i have defined
it like phi
and alpha is symbols i don't want that
okay i want y to be a function of x and
y
so i'll redefine this bar file okay i'll
redefine this bar phi
to be a function not a symbol
okay we have function bar five
but explicitly mentioned that it is a
function of x and y
and now when i display this rfi and
please note that if i just write down
the variable name here it displays
this thing it's equivalent to the
display thing
okay except that when i write display
it doesn't get doesn't get named as an
output cell
uh anyway so this is our bar phi which
is a function of x and y now i want to
apply my laplacian operator on this
let's see what happens uh on wall pipe
you see okay so i need not actually have
a definite pawn for my
for my uh my area stress function in
general also i can
as if i'm writing down theory on a piece
of paper i can use the symbolic python
so this is a very powerful thing
okay similarly i can use the by harmonic
thing
okay you see exactly what we had written
down in our
notes uh this is exactly that one
next uh let us
consider uh let us consider
a specific form for this area stress
function
okay so what i mean to say is that
instead of keeping it like a
this unknown general function of x and y
let's say
that we put bar phi
as in the form of a
quadratic polynomial okay so
now what i would need to do
is to set up this bar phi as a 2 0
x square plus a 1 1 x
y plus a 0 to y square
in order to do that i need these
coefficients okay now if i just
simply write a to 0 a 1 1
a 0 2 it will give me an error i can
show you that
ok so suppose i write like this a 2 0
into x
square plus a 1 1
into x y as you can expect this is going
to give me an error
okay
okay so as you see i mean
it's not defined of course it gives an
error now
in order to correct this i'll have to
first define these things
okay so
let me actually demonstrate another
thing in between
so i'm in this cell now uh suppose i
want to
input another cell just before it so
what i can do is i can go to this insert
and just use this insert cell above
or while i'm here i can press
escape and then just press the letter
a a for above so you see
a cell is inserted a blank cell is
inserted above the current cell
so in this cell i will uh i'll
define my symbols a 2 0 a 1 1 and a 0 2
so a 2 0 a 1 1 a 0 2
is equal to same dot symbols just as
before
now just use this underscore so that
the symbols are defined in a nice
fashion uh with the subscripts okay
so you'll see in a moment what i mean
okay so
now all this while i have been using the
shift enter
i can also do a ctrl enter so that it
does not go to the next cell it it gets
implemented whatever is present in this
cell it gets implemented but it doesn't
go to the next cell so ctrl
enter okay it has done what it needs to
do
but it didn't go to the next set so
i just display all these things a 2 0
a 1 1 a 0 2 okay
and now if i do a ctrl enter again it
will stay in the same cell but it will
display these things
you see and nicely with the proper
subscripts
because uh these subscripts are coming
out because in the definition of these
symbols
uh i had put this underscores
that's why it's coming out anyway so now
if we come to this cell
and do a control enter
now it it works out fine without any
error okay
and suppose i want to display this part
5
now it is going to display properly ok
now with this thing
i can actually uh i can actually
use this bar file uh to
obtain specific forms for my stresses
okay so let's do that sigma xx is equal
to i know that sigma xx is equal to
del square phi uh del y square
okay uh so
let me actually describe this thing
using a markdown cell
okay so
we now obtain the press fields
using
don't worry too much about this latex
syntax that i'm using
very quickly i'll do this this
is not important to the understanding of
of symbolic python at all but this is
only for
visual appeal
try to do this as fast as possible
all right let's see if this thing
renders properly
all right that's what i wanted sigma xx
is equal to del square phi del y square
sigma yy is equal to del square by del x
square and sigma xy
uh is equal to minus del square by del x
del y
so we go to the next cell and uh since
we do not have a new cell in
below it we can of course press another
shift enter here or
we can press a b okay so we press escape
and press b so that introduces a new
cell
we need it and we press enter to enter
it okay
so now we actually do the maths behind
it so sigma xx
is equal to uh
sorry y comma two
sigma yy is equal to same dot
if sorry part pi
x comma 2 and sigma x y
is equal to sim dot if part 5
uh x so
uh into x comma y here
and let's not forget the minus sign okay
and lastly i need to display everything
let's see if this works all right that's
fine
and we know that these things are
correct okay so we can just
uh orderly check this now
all this is fine but uh as you know as
you can see
earlier uh i had been
uh let me do a full screen here
that will free up more space uh
earlier i had defined this laplacian
operators and by harmonic operators
you can think of these sigmas this the
stress fields also
as uh as as operators okay
because these have like specific
definitions
so you can define them also uh
now if you keep on changing the the phi
of course you are going to end up with
different different
sigmas
as you have more and more complicated
air stress functions
uh the more you realize the utility
of using the symbolic python now
before we go into anything else
i would like to demonstrate
something rather useful okay so
till now we have defined this quadratic
polynomial uh area stress function
but suppose we want uh we we have this
kind of a
four degree polynomial okay or maybe
even a fifty degree polynomial let's
let's work with the fifth degree
polynomial
so that will involve a little bit more
typing
but let's do it do this quickly
okay so i'm trying to minimize the
amount of typing that i have to do
for one because for a fifth degree
polynomial i
need these coefficients like a five zero
a four one a three two
uh and eight two three a
4 8 0 5 all right
here also i'll have these things
for 1 3 2
2 3 1 4
zero five all right uh
and i can immediately write this
as a five zero into
x is five plus a
4 1 into x 4
y plus a a 2 into
x cubed y
square plus a 2 3 into
x square point y
plus a 1 4 into x
into y 4 and finally a 0
5 into y fifth power
and let's display this
okay of course we can we can use our
our our ipython kind of display also
here
let's try that okay
so r5 again i'm using the latex kind of
syntax index
okay so this var5 with a with a
backslash here this is the latex thing
and this wi-fi is the variable of r5
that i have defined in the previous line
so if i do this you see
it actually gets outputted in this nice
fashion and this is the wire file we
want
we want to work with so now
just as we had done in the previous
example
we can obtain the the sigmas but before
that
uh we want to check what happens with
the by harmonic equation
okay so what happens if we if we take
the pi harmonic of this phi
because we note that before we go on to
do anything we must check
uh or we must find the conditions uh
uh under which the a given error stress
function satisfies the by harmonic
equation
okay so the by harmonic of
this bar phi okay i can use this by
harmonic because i've already defined it
uh i'll get this this kind of a thing
now see
this gives me the correct answer but
it's not really in the form that i want
okay what i'll do is remember one of the
earliest things that we learned in
symbolic python expand
and again use that okay so
okay so by harmonic of r5 and in an
expanded fashion
this is the entire thing so this is
something that you would obtain if you
do
did this entire thing uh the by
operating
uh i mean finding the by harmonic of
this
phi uh on a piece of paper okay now
you see the conditions which must be
satisfied
uh so so you understand that this by
harmonic
pi that must be set equal to 0 and that
will be equal to 0
only if the individual coefficients of x
and y are set equal to 0
okay so very easy
to extract the uh
to extract the the coefficients of x
and y so all that you have to do is
uh to take the output of this
okay so what we can do is uh
we can just just
copy paste this
and do a coefficient of x let's see
this works you see
the first coefficient of x's is 24 a 1 4
that we have here next one is 24 a32
that we have here and next one is 120
a5 0 and also we have here in a similar
fashion
we can extract the coefficient of y
i just copy paste this line and just
instead of coefficient of x we'll write
coefficient of y
you have to enter and again you see
12805
24 823 comes from here and this 24a41
comes from here
so these are the are the two things
which must be set equal to zero
okay so right now i am not demonstrating
to you how we can use this as part of
the problem
but the good news is that there are very
easy ways
to extract the coefficients of of x and
y from
a relatively long from a relatively long
uh polynomial okay so this is a
relatively long polynomial
i mean we we will operate with things
which are even longer than this
and then you will see that how useful it
is to extract things
out like this at one go okay uh
now uh we can also do a similar thing
with
uh with the the fourth order polynomial
4 degree polynomial and such other
things
for third degree polynomial you won't
need to extract anything like this
because that satisfies the by harmonic
equation identically
now we have been talking about these
differentiations
in a similar fashion you can you can
obtain integrations
okay it's very easy so as a very simple
demonstration
uh let's do the integration of x you
don't even have to specify with respect
to what because
there's nothing else here so okay so
this is x square by 2
you know that the so usually on a piece
of paper when you do this sort of
integration you write a plus c
the constant the unknown arbitrary
constant of integration
that we have not written here but you
understand okay
yes i mean you are after all the human
being operating this computer so you
understand this there
all right now suppose instead of this we
we
want to obtain x square
okay the integration of x square uh that
also
come very easily that is x cube by 3
furthermore if you want to do
let's say
x square y all right x square y but
integrated with respect to
uh let's say y this time can this be
done
sure enough uh it is giving us the
correct result
so x is being treated as a constant here
and it is only the y which is getting
integrated so these kinds of things uh
from the from the point of view of
applied elasticity is very useful for
finding out
the second moments of area or the
moments of inertia
of a cross section these integrations uh
so uh another
application would be uh finding out
the moment okay so the bending moment
uh that would be
basically for for a cross section that
would be the integration
of sigma x x y so those those sorts of
things so we'll actually demonstrate
the use of those when we when you go
into the solution of problems
of 2d elasticity okay so with this i
think uh
i have more or less covered uh things i
wanted to
cover from this calculus point of view
and also i mean the calculus in
connection with 2d elasticity
uh just another very important note
uh you see when we are defining these
symbols okay so this is a very basic
thing
but at the same time i think it's quite
advanced also
okay so people don't uh don't take care
of this
thing when you're when they're learning
first of all but it does make a
difference as
you proceed please note that
when we are defining our symbols like x
y
okay so what what did we write if you go
back okay we go back
earlier one of the first things that we
wrote uh
was this thing right this x
comma y is equal to uh sim okay let's
copy this
let's copy this go back down and do this
again okay just
just because we want to
no problem now suppose suppose
instead of this x y i want to call this
something else okay suppose i want to
call
my variable okay because you see the the
visual depiction of the variable
as it is as it is shown by by the symbol
x or y
and the name that is given to that
variable those are two separate things
so
that's what i want to demonstrate here
okay so the visual depiction of the
symbol is x but the name of the variable
is rabbit
okay i've deliberately taken this grade
i mean this weird name
rabbit okay just to demonstrate my point
okay so
if i do a shift enter it's a valid input
okay
and now if i do rabbit it will just
display x
you see similarly i could have done
a rabbit tiger
and assigned y to tiger and now if i
display rabbit for my tiger
it's going to display x and y okay now
things can become really crazy okay so
suppose instead of this
you do something uh
like this y comma x is equal to
m dot symbols okay
x comma y okay
now if you do a shift enter it is still
a valid input
and this is where things can go i mean
really really crazy
suppose you tried y here it gives you x
okay and let's say display y comma
x
okay so y is x and x is y
okay so i mean if
you want to do it in the i python style
of display
uh you would write something like this
that that y
is equal to uh
this is crazy but let's do this okay
let me just make my point
sorry um
[Music]
you see already things have gone really
really crazy here
so uh
so what i want to show you here is that
my x here the x is the math x this x is
the math x
okay and this is the variable y
and this is x and
fine let's see what this gives yeah and
already you can see
such a source of confusion okay this is
perfectly all right
okay mathematically this is all right
but
you understand here that this can be a
big big source of confusion
so unless you want to see the world burn
don't do these kinds of things please
please do not do this kind of things
and problem is once you do these kinds
of crazy things
whatever you had defined earlier okay
that
completely gets erased so now if
whatever
whatever fresh input you have given that
is the thing
which is in memory for say for for
jupiter notebook and that is what it
operates on
and things can go horribly horribly
disastrously wrong
if you persist with this so delete this
thing
okay unless you want to see the word
burn okay delete this line
and and you can actually delete this
entire cell
well you can go to this cell and
forgotten so edit maybe here it is
so you can delete cells like this or the
easy way is
just press escape and press d twice
okay d okay d for delete twice
dt so similarly here also
this this this blank cell that you see
here that can be deleted by pressing d
twice d d one okay
and uh i think this rabbit tiger
business was much better
to keep that okay and the best thing of
course is to just delete all
of these things again d d
and we don't want anything to burn we
want to
have a nice stable system so x y is
x y all right uh
i just wanted to point that out uh
you can also have uh i mean
fancier uh definitions of symbols like
this
so p n p outsole for pressure in and
pressure out
maybe for some kind of pressure vessel
kind of problems
and here you can
actually go quite fancy
so these are the kinds of things which
will be useful to you when you
write your report for your term project
you see i mean it gets outputted in a
nice fashion okay
so that's it uh all right
now uh
so with this i'll end this uh this
discussion
and i hope this this bit that we
discussed regarding the by harmonic
the laplacian and the stress functions
that will be that you will pick up very
soon
and will be able to use this to solve uh
our real
problems okay the technical problems
of 2d elasticity uh in a nice
systematic fashion all right thank you
very much i'll
finish i'll end this lecture here
thank you